10 ways to have better conversations. This is gonna
be a reaction video on one of the most popular Ted
Talks that exists. It's got over 30 million views
just between YouTube and Ted and I'm going to have
Celeste speak for herself on her 10 tips and
then I'm going to offer my 2 cents, as soon
as you hear her, share her tip, offer my 2 cents
contribution on the concept she's talking about.
Counting down, here we go, no time wasted. Number
10, Celeste would say don't try to multitask.
And I don't mean just set down your cellphone
or your tablet or your car keys or
whatever is in your hand, I mean be present;
be in that moment. Don't be thinking about
your argument you have with your boss, don't
be thinking about what you're going to have
for dinner. If you want to get out of the
conversation, get out of the conversation,
but don't be half in it and half out of it.
My take on this is asking the question, asking
yourself the question, maybe asking the group
the question or the person you're talking with:
are you present? It's one of the most powerful
questions that was asked to me in my own life. So,
are you present? Number 9, don't pontificate. She
shares absolutely one of my favorite quotes from
Bill Nye and we'll just hear her say it in her
voice. If you wanted to state your opinion without
any opportunity for response or argument
or pushback or growth, write a blog.
Now, there's a really good reason why I don't
allow pundits on my show, because they're
really boring. If they're a conservative, they're
going to hate Obama and food stamps and abortion,
if they're a liberal, they're going to hate
big banks and oil corporations and Dick Cheney,
totally predictable. And you don't want to be like
that, you need to enter every conversation assuming
that you have something to learn. The famed
therapist M. Scott Peck said that true listening
requires a setting aside of oneself and sometimes
that means setting aside your personal opinion. He
said that sensing this acceptance, the speaker will
become less and less vulnerable and more and more
likely to open up the inner recesses of his or her
mind to the listener. Again, assume that you have
something to learn. Bill Nye, everyone you will
ever meet knows something that you don't. I put it
this way, everybody is an expert in something. When
you're up here, everybody's down there and it's not
very connecting for conversation. In other words,
as your awesomeness goes up, your relatedness goes
down. Number 8, stay out of the weeds. Frankly,
people don't care about the years, the names,
the dates, all those details that you're struggling
to come up with in your mind, they don't care. What
they care about is you. They care about what you're
like, what you have in common. So, forget the details,
leave them out. Last invite, you use open-ended
questions. In this case, take a cue from journalists.
Start your questions with: who, what, where, when,
why or how. If you put in a complicated question,
you're going to get a simple answer out. If I
ask you, "Were you terrified?" You're gonna respond
to the most powerful word in that sentence which
is terrified and the answer is, "Yes, I was or no, I
wasn't." "Were you angry?" "Yes, I was very angry." Let
them describe it, they're the ones that know.
Try asking them things like what was that like?
How did that feel? Because then they might have
to stop for a moment and think about it and you're
gonna get a much more interesting response. My take
on this, a little more specific. I would invite you
to use questions that only begin with how or what
and not why. Why questions typically invite people
to defend and they have some judgment embedded in
them. So, just ask questions that begin with
how or what. Celeste says go with the flow.
That means thoughts will come into your mind
and you need to let them go out of your mind.
We've heard interviews often in which a guest
is talking for several minutes and then the
host comes back in and asked a question
which seems like it comes out of nowhere
or it's already been answered, that means the host
probably stopped listening 2 minutes ago because
he thought of this really clever question and he
was just bound and determined to say that and we
do the exact same thing. We're sitting there having
a conversation with someone and then we remember
that time that we met Hugh Jackman in a coffee
shop and we stopped listening. Stories and ideas
are going to come to you, you need to let them come
and let them go. My take with go with the flow is
actually continue to be curious to that person.
Curiosity, when it's natural and it's genuine is
kind of like the natural flowingness of a river. It
might wind and take you to some unexpected places
but it's still going to be flowing and that is
really great for conversation. And so, be curious
also as you're listening. Number 5, if you don't
know, say you don't know. Now, people on the radio
especially on NPR are much more aware that they're
going on the record. And so, they're more careful
about what they claim to be an expert
in and what they claim to know for sure.
Do that, err on the side of caution. Talk should not
be cheap. Number 4, don't equate your experience
with theirs. If they're talking about having lost
a family member, don't start talking about the time
that you lost a family member. If they're talking
about the trouble that they're having at work,
don't tell them about how much you hate your
job, it's not the same. It is never the same. All
experiences are individual and more importantly,
it is not about you. You don't need to take that
moment to prove how amazing you are or how
much you've suffered. Somebody asked Stephen
Hawking once what his IQ was and he says, "I have
no idea. People who brag about their IQ's are losers."
Conversations are not a promotional opportunity.
Just don't say, "I know how you feel." You don't,
you're not them. You didn't have the exact same
experience and they will be sure to point out,
they will be quick to point out that they didn't
have the exact same experience as you. The tool for
that is maybe describe the world as you think
they see it and let them correct you and add
in. Number 3, try not to repeat yourself. It's
condescending and it's really boring. And we tend
to do it a lot, especially in work conversations or
in conversations with our kids, we have a point to
make so we just keep rephrasing it over and over,
don't do that. I'm not gonna repeat what Celeste just
said. Number 2, listen more. This is not the last
one but it is the most important one. Listen. I
cannot tell you how many really important people
have said that listening is perhaps the most,
the number 1 most important skill that you
could develop. Buddha said, and I'm paraphrasing,
if your mouth is open, you're not
learning. And Calvin Coolidge said
no man ever listened his way out of a job. Why do
we not listen to each other? Number 1, we'd rather
talk. When I'm talking, I'm in control. I don't have
to hear anything I'm not interested in. I'm the
center of attention, I can bolster my own identity
but there's another reason, we get distracted. The
average person talks at about 225 words per minute,
but we can listen at up to 500 words per minute.
So, our minds are filling in those other 275
words and look, I know it takes effort and energy
to actually pay attention to someone but if
you can't do that, you're not in a conversation.
You're just 2 people shouting out
barely related sentences in the same place.
You have to... you have to listen to one another.
Stephen Covey said it very beautifully. He said
most of us don't listen with the intent to
understand. We listen with the intent to reply.
The question I would give you that a teacher of
mine gave to me to help you listen more is one of
my favorite questions, 2 words: what else. Listen
to what somebody else said and then just say
what else? What else? You could rephrase that but
just what else? What else? And number 1, be brief.
All of this boils down to the same
basic concept and it is this one:
be interested in other people. You know, I grew up
with a very famous grandfather and there was kind
of a ritual in my home. People would come over to
talk to my grandparents and after they would leave,
my mother would come over to us and she'd say,
"Do you know who that was? She was the runner up
to Miss America, he was the mayor of Sacramento, she
won a Pulitzer prize, he's a Russian ballet dancer."
And I started... I kind of grew up assuming
everyone has some hidden amazing thing about them
and I honestly I think it's what makes me a
better host. I keep my mouth shut as often as
I possibly can, I keep my mind open and I'm always
prepared to be amazed and I'm never disappointed.
You do the same thing. Go out, talk to people,
listen to people and most importantly,
be prepared to be amazed. How can I add to
that? I'll keep it brief. If you love this
video, I chop up short clips of these videos and
post them all over social media so if you just
want like the 60 second, 120 second bit, go ahead
and search me on any social media platform. Would
love to meet and be in conversation with you
there. I'm Chad Littlefield, have an awesome day.